(drawer opening)
(explorative music)
- The world you live in
today was sketched on paper
by European men.
Men who looked like me.
Men who at first were just
curious and adventurous
but soon whose motives morphed
into an insatiable greed.
A confidence that their way
was better than everyone elses.
This confidence led to arguably
the most influential series
of events in human history.
At least the history
that affects you and me,
a 500 year project of moving people
and weapons and germs
and language and violence
to every corner of our earth
and in the process, gathering
and taking home stuff to
make them richer, metal,
rubber, tea, sugar, and human bodies.
This isn't a history lesson.
You won't hear me talk a
lot about dates and names.
Instead, this is the first of three videos
where I want to show
you how this happened.
How Europe, a continent full
of poor, miserable farmers
took over the entire
world, and in the process,
they shaped it, they
shaped it to their way
of thinking and speaking and doing things.
So this is part one of how
Europe stole the world.
(dramatic music)
(relaxing music)
I am out here on a bit of
an excursion near the sea,
but I wanna pause this video
because I need to tell you
about the sponsor of today's video,
which is Better Help,
a company that is trying
to help you improve
your mental health.
I am a giant fan of therapy.
I've said it before, I
will continue to say it.
I think therapy is way
underutilized in our society.
We all have mental health issues,
whether we like it or not,
whether they're diagnosed or not,
and Better Help is trying to make therapy
which is just working through the things
in your mind, more accessible
and I'm a giant supporter of that mission.
I've been in therapy for several years,
it has changed the way that I think,
it has changed the way that
I approach my relationships.
It has changed me,
I can say that unambiguously
and very genuinely.
What Better Help is, is a
platform to make therapy
more accessible to people,
anyone around the whole world.
It's not bound by geography.
So instead of looking for a therapist like
in your local town, you go on
to Better Help, you sign up.
You take a very short quiz
and they match you with
somebody in their huge network
of like tens of thousands of therapists.
Once you're matched, you
can start communicating
with a therapist in as
little as like 48 hours,
which if you've ever looked
for a therapist before,
that is very, very quick.
That is very easy
and that's what Better
Help's trying to do,
is just use technology to
make therapy more accessible.
I'm a big fan of that.
You can choose how you do your therapy.
You can do it over the phone.
You can do it over video call.
You could even do it over like messaging,
if you don't want to talk.
Better Help is not like
a self-help program.
It's not a crisis line,
it's legitimate therapy
that is done securely
on the internet.
This is why over three
million people are on
the Better Help platform,
taking control of their mental health.
So if you want to get in on
this, try Better Help out.
There is a link in my description
it is BetterHelp.com/JohnnyHarris.
Clicking that link helps
support this channel,
but it also gives you
10% off your first month
of Better Help, so you can try it out.
Better Help is already really affordable.
There's even financial
aid for those who need it.
Thank you Better Help for
supporting my channel,
for supporting this video
and for making therapy more accessible.
Okay, now back to this
incredibly important story
on how Europe stole the world.
Yes, I'm gonna be looking at a lot of maps
to understand this issue
because drawing on the map
is how they did things.
(dramatic music)
To understand how Europe stole the world,
we need to rewind to
back when the map looked
a little different, hold on.
Back in like 1450, the
world map looked like this.
I mean, Europe was just a
bunch of smaller kingdoms.
The borders look so
different than they do today.
They were all pretty small potatoes.
Well actually there
actually were no potatoes.
Those wouldn't arrive to
Europe for another 50 years
but the fact is there wasn't an abundance
of anything in Europe.
Instead, Europeans were just
farmers barely scraping by,
constantly in debt to
a few rich landlords.
Life in Europe was scarce and miserable.
Meanwhile, there was a
bunch of other empires
around the world that were thriving.
There was this big empire
over in the Middle East.
They had silk and then over here in India,
you had a big empire with spices
and luxurious cotton fabrics.
Then of course there was
the big dynasty in China
that had by this time already
invented gun powder, porcelain
and really sophisticated ships,
that they could use to
sail around the world.
Oh, and all of these empires
were trading with one another,
making all of them even richer.
They all had better
everything than Europe did
and miserable Europeans
eventually wanted in
on all the trade.
(funky music)
So that's kind of the context
here that sets the stage
for Europe taking over the world.
The first two countries that
wanted in on all this trade
and set out to explore were
the countries that today
we know is Spain and Portugal.
So they start looking for a
land route to get them east.
They start moving east and nope.
Oh, look, it's the Ottoman Empire,
a very powerful Middle Eastern empire
that's run by Muslims.
Meanwhile, Spain and
Portugal are hella Catholic
and they're not being super
nice to Muslims or Jews.
So the Ottomans are like,
"No, we're not gonna let you
"pass through our land to get
in on the trade in the east.
"Oh and by the way, you
can't even afford our taxes.
"You're miserable Europeans
without a lot of money,
"so go away."
They're gonna need another way to go east.
Portugal's work around was literally to go
around the continent of Africa.
Stopping along the coast to trade
with the wealthy African
empires along the way.
This is a huge moment
because it actually worked.
It's near the end of the 1400s
and the Portuguese are now going nuts.
They're sending ships around this route
that they figured out,
trading with the east
and suddenly the Portuguese are dressing
in luxurious fabrics.
They're using cloves and
cinnamon and black pepper
to make their food actually taste good.
Wait a minute, you're telling me
they didn't have black pepper before this?
Geez, miserable indeed.
- You must have some peppers.
- So the age of exploration has begun.
Miserable Europe is doing
something about their situation.
Going out to get in on the
thriving trade in the east.
But remember, this isn't
about conquering land.
It's about trading, for now.
(dramatic music)
Okay, so now Spain sees
Portugal hitting the jackpot
and they're kind of jelly,
they want in on this too.
They need to establish their
own trade route to Asia
but they wanted to do things
a little bit differently.
Instead of following Portugal's lead
and going around Africa,
they listen to a pitch
from this Italian sailor
and this sailor wants them
to fund his new startup
called what if we sailed west
to get to Asia instead of
east, super promising name.
Now remember at this point,
people in Europe thought
that the world looked like
this, the logic was like,
oh we can just hop over to
Asia by going this other way.
So Spain was like, yes, great
idea, high risk, high return.
Do it Columbus.
Well, it turns out the world
does not look like this
and instead over here,
there are a couple of
massive continents that Columbus ran into.
But like many of us confident white dudes,
Columbus was like, yeah,
I know exactly where I am.
We're like in the Indies right now.
Like over those guys over
there, those are Indians.
Yep, I can feel it.
But instead he was like in Cuba,
but despite the mansplaining,
Columbus kind of found exactly
what he was looking for
and more.
Great empires with rich culture and food
and precious metal that weren't
available to him back home,
he was right on target.
So he's like, "All right,
guys, let's trade."
But then he is like, "Wait a minute.
"These people don't have armies or navies
"protecting their stuff."
So this must be kind of a different place,
different land with different rules
and this is where the
biggest light bulb moment
of the century goes
off in this guy's head.
"Change of plans, boys." says Columbus,
"We're going to claim this land."
And everyone was like, "Wait, what?"
"You heard me, we are claiming this land."
and the boys are like, "Wait,
"weren't we here to like
trade with great empires.
"Portugal's been doing this
"for like all these
years and getting rich."
and he's like, "No,
they don't have armies.
"They're just letting us show up
"and like be here without a fight.
"So obviously that means they don't mind
"if we just like claim the land."
I mean, I'm taking some
creative Liberty here
on like explaining what
Columbus was thinking.
But like, look at the
letter that he wrote.
Here's the letter that
Columbus wrote back to the king
and queen, reporting on what he saw.
He writes back saying that
he discovered many islands,
inhabited by numerous peoples
and then I took possession of them
for our most fortunate king,
making public proclamation
and unfurling his standard, his flag,
with no one making any resistance,
no one making any resistance.
Spain and Portugal set out to trade.
They sent out to like explore
and understand and get in
on the global economy.
But Columbus's realization
was instead of trading,
they could actually just
claim land for themselves
and this changed everything.
After all, no one was
making any resistance.
This moment is the foundation
upon which all European imperialism grows.
I'll show you.
(dramatic music)
It's the moment that would
give us the first big division
in the minds of Europeans.
The thing we wrote on paper, the old world
versus the new world.
This is really familiar language to us now
but it was invented in this moment.
The new world was now seen as
land that could be claimed.
It was fair game to go conquer
because they didn't have
big armies or a Christian King.
"Forget trade with the
east," said, Columbus,
"There's a bunch of land that we can go
"take over in the west."
and the race was on.
(inspiring music)
Spain and Portugal didn't
wanna fight with each
other over all this land,
this conquest that they
were about to undertake.
So they got together and
they drew some lines.
No, literally they just
drew two straight lines.
We have Africa, we have Europe
and then we have this line.
Everything left of this line is Spains,
everything to the right is Portugal.
This is literally one of the original maps
where they actually drew
these straight lines
and divided the world into two.
But let's look at this on a
nicer looking map, please.
There we go, now we can see very clearly.
Oh, look now we understand
why they speak Portuguese
in Brazil.
So Spain and Portugal
now have their spheres
of the world that they can go conquer.
They didn't ask anyone.
They didn't negotiate with the locals.
They just drew these straight lines.
The Pope actually helped them
broker the deal, classic.
But again, this is a huge
thing that I want to explain
in this series, that
these were not just lines.
They weren't just like lines on paper.
They were actually a shift
in the paradigm, a new way
of thinking about the world,
no one making any resistance.
It was a story that Europeans
could now tell themselves.
Old world versus new world,
claimed versus unclaimed,
a new way of thinking.
Think I'm being overly
simplistic about this?
Let me show you something.
(dramatic music)
There's one, two, three, four.
These were a juicy find.
I found this amazing
Portuguese nautical Atlas.
It's a bunch of maps that the
Portuguese Navy drafted up
right after these two
lines divided the world
between Spain and Portugal
and it is an amazing series
of maps, but not only
because it's visually stunning,
but also because it lets us into the mind
of how the Portuguese saw the world
after they divided it with Spain.
(relaxing music)
This Atlas reads like a story book.
It's like the Portuguese were so giddy
about giving themselves permission
to steal half the world,
that they had to write a
children's story about it.
That's what it feels like,
that's not what it is,
but just look at this thing,
here's the title page.
You can see that at the
center is the sphere
that was given to Portuguese.
Brazil, Africa, what
is now the East Indies
and here on every corner,
you see these angels that are
blowing wind into the sales
of the Portuguese who are out
on their land grab mission.
So this is just the title page.
The subsequent pages of
this Atlas are closeups
on different regions.
This is the Caribbean over here.
Look, this will become Cuba.
This will become Haiti, Dominican
Republic, North America,
South America, all of this
unclaimed up for grabs.
Here, our story depicts all these flags.
Some of them are Spanish flags
on the islands on their side
of the line, but then
you have Portuguese flags
on the Portuguese side of the line.
The status of this land,
according to the fantasy
of the Portuguese,
changing from unclaimed
to claimed by men on ships
with Christian crosses on their sails,
showing up and planting flags.
This was like playing
a board game to them.
(dramatic music)
Here's another page.
This one's a close up on Brazil,
and look, we've got people over here.
We've got dark skinned, naked people
with primitive tools and no homes.
It looks like down here in Brazil,
they spend their days chopping
wood naked and dancing,
all while being gazed upon by
fantastical birds and dragons?
This was an official Naval
Atlas drafted for the king
and if its message wasn't clear enough
on how these people should be depicted,
the Atlas has a little info
box up here where they say
that the Brazilians are quote,
"Savage and very brutal."
This is one of the first atlases ever made
and it wasn't really a navigation tool.
It was much more a declaration
of a new way of seeing the world.
Unclaimed territory, sub-human people,
all of it up for grabs by Christian boats.
So yeah, this is how it all started.
Under this new paradigm, both
empires expanded very quickly
forcing the Spanish and
Portuguese languages
across the ocean,
mining, vast quantities of
silver, creating plantations
for tobacco and sugar
and in the process, massacring
the people who were living
in this new world, both
with their weapons,
but also with their European city germs
that the people being conquered
didn't have immunity to.
I mean, this whole thing
started with curiosity,
with a thirst to get in
on the trade in Asia.
But soon as this fantasy of unclaimed land
came into the picture, the goal shifted,
the project pivoted and soon
Europe was telling themselves
a new story that they,
enlightened Christians,
were entitled to claim it
and while the story starts
with Spain and Portugal,
soon it spread.
Other European countries
poked their head up
from their farm work and said,
"Hey, we're white Christians
also, we know how to sail.
"We want in on this
story of unclaimed land."
And that's the next chapter of the story.
One that I will tell you in
the next part of the series.